hmmm it's like Oh No
good morning believe nation today's
message is fine your own voice too much
I'll pause I'm trying to go deeper I'm
trying to work on a diaphragm having a
deeper voice a / - you're Harrison Ford
together overall I say that good morning
believe nation today's message is find
your own voice over to you Harrison Ford
the only advice I've ever offered
young actors is to try and figure out
how to do it for yourself never be
caught with the with the idea that that
you can imitate someone else's success
as much as you might admire what someone
else does
don't try and imitate that find your own
way find what find your own voice
find your own feelings and that will
make will give you a unique opportunity
so what do you think I think I'm
actually facing that challenge right now
of being mentored by you and just in my
life when I was younger I would look to
people with a little bit more experience
a little bit more wisdom to get advice
from them but every time I would try to
just completely imitate them and pass on
their message which might not be
something I believe always in my core
something I could learn from them but
not in my core it never came out right I
didn't feel authentic about it as you're
trying to grow as you try and you know
you look at Steve Jobs or you look at
anyone in your life and you're like I
want to be like them you don't want to
be them you want to take things that
really make them amazing and apply to
your life to make the inner you look
more beautiful on the outside versus
just faking it so this is really too
hard - what I'm thinking about right now
what I'm struggling with
I still haven't fully solved you know
where I find the balance
you know having my own word or thinking
for myself even I would say go so far
but it's a learning process and I think
just thinking about putting it on your
radar
it is important so for those you don't
remember alex is a friend of the friend
of the channel and helps me run Toronto
again it's also this business that we're
filming out of every time that I've
gotten advice from others who tried to
model others and it's the name of this
channel modeling well into masters I've
always had to tweak it you know I would
get frustrated with my media coach
because she asked me to do something
that wouldn't work her way wouldn't work
but she would guide me down the path a
little bit further and I don't have to
tweak it for my own purposes I look at
this business it's salsa dancing school
when we're teaching salsa as an example
there are moves that we have to teach
like a level one class is a level one
class and when you do in the first class
is the same across every class no matter
who's teaching it what the delivery and
the execution of each instructor has to
be different we're all welcoming we're
all friendly we're all about family you
know it's on Alex's shirt but the way
that I teach is slightly different in
Alex's style slightly different than
Lisa style then Lily style your Alex is
really funny you know he makes a lot of
bloopers he makes a lot of people laugh
he's you know his joke ease entertaining
he's a character you know I'm not I'm
more passion you know I'm more believe
so if I tried to copy a like sort of
Alec tried to copy me we wouldn't
succeed like I can't be better at being
Alex and Alex and so it's a challenge
also for us and mentoring our other
instructors that like just because it
works for Alex doesn't mean it will work
for Lily and Lily needs to find her own
voice too in teaching yes still the same
moves but teaching it in her way that
feels authentic to her instead of
putting on somebody else's mask you know
for you guys watching whoever you look
up to if it's my channel or jobs or
whoever it is you can learn a lot from
their success it can it can inspire you
just to see where they came from what
they built it can also give you
practical how to's like what is the next
step that I need to follow not just the
inspirational side but tactics but
recognize that you will not be the next
Steve Jobs by doing everything like
Steve Jobs
you have to tweak the things he did to
make it work
for you and instead of even thinking
about being the next Steve Jobs we're
worried about being the first you out
there and I think it's an important
process to find your own voice so the
question is a today is where do you find
a breaking point between being true to
yourself but still stepping out of your
comfort zone leave it in the comments
below we will join in the discussion we
also want to give a quick shout out to
Marco Polo for buying a copy of the book
thank you so much really means a lot so
for your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso okay I'll throw it to you
ready no okay so the question today
today is I know what I want to say it's
just not coming out leave in the
comments below we'll join in the sky